[Music]
hawaii is the only place in the u.s
where humpbacks breed and nurse their
young
[Music]
born with very little fat calves would
soon freeze to death in the cold waters
of alaska
[Applause]
mothers come to these clear shallow
waters to avoid predators
[Music]
that there's a catch
there's no food here
the moms go hungry
losing up to 40 percent of their weight
raising their calves
[Music]
it's a sacrifice that pays off
humpback populations are increasing
[Music]
the park is just one place to see these
giants of the deep
but they are not its biggest attraction
two massive volcanoes are
the first is kilauea
one of the most active volcanoes on
earth
the lava lake inside this crater can be
more than
750 feet deep
its lava flows can reach the sea ten
miles away
kilauea is so big that even its vents
and craters are huge
starting in 1983
one of these vents erupted for 35 years
it produced so much lava that it covered
the coast road
burying it more than 100 feet deep
to the west is the second volcano and
it's the biggest on the planet
this is mauna loa
rising more than 56 000 feet above its
base
much taller than even mount everest
the park exists thanks to eruptions over
hundreds of thousands of years
where hardened lava forms a solid
foundation for life
close to the source
poisonous gas fumes escape from hot
vents
called fumaroles
this landscape is often swept clean by
molten lava
[Music]
it's one of the most barren and toxic
environments on earth
[Music]
nature has had to adapt to living in
this land of fire
[Music]
a wingless lava cricket
after an eruption she is the first
creature to take up residence
in this hostile landscape
the ultimate pioneer
[Music]
no larger than a fingernail
she survives by eating morsels of food
that blow in with the ocean breeze
[Music]
nobody knows where she comes from where
she goes for how long she lives
in many ways
she's a mystery
[Music]
you